[Music]
lester said he saw her head west can you
just calm down and think a minute this
is all a misunderstanding haven't i been
telling you there's something off with
mabel she's got those crazy killer eyes
like lies at three in the morning please
don't tell that story she and jessica
lang came to me after an evening at
studio 54 and i had had a few cocktails
stop
mabel is a sweet young woman who
promised not to keep secrets
is this your hat my hat i thought i'd
lost it
there she is what
tie dye guy
it's tie-dye guy okay we we got to
follow them i'm going to get my car you
stay on all right i'll wait wait you
have a car go after them on foot and
then call me when you know where they
are and then i'll swing by and pick you
up okay i'll wait
you pay for parking here this is bad
they're getting away you want them i'm
on them but i cannot run a camry stay on
them
oh no they don't see me
so where are we going it's in teaneck
gw bridge
[Music]
welcome to new york
thank you ma'am
oliver i can't i can't hear you are you
there yeah i might cut out a little bit
but stay on
oh
oh thank god they're stuck in traffic
where are you
i'll take one
wait are you at that pretzel cart i want
one read on the toppings what what
toppings there's mustard and salt yeah
but you know sometimes there's honey
mustard is it dante tell him oliver
wants his usual are you dante yep oliver
wants as usual
[Music]
i'm coming around are you still on 88
yeah
traffic's moving where are you
turn around
[Music]
very inconspicuous
we blend in by standing out
what are you doing no no no no you drive
because oh
i got to record and also my driver's
license expired 25 years ago keep your
eyes on that camera
[Music]
you